Uh, hi I'm Ed Plumacher and I'm here with the Oral History Project
and with Devon Fernandez it is Sunday March twenty second [add year]
and we are conducting this interview at the West Islip Public Library in West Islip, New
York and uh I'd just like to welcome you, Devin, and thank you for uh providing us
with, uh, with your story and I'm sure a lot of people will benefit from hearing about it.
Um, you know I'd just like you to just start off, just tell us a little bit about yourself I know you
were born in New York, you were born in the Bronx tell us, you know, who Devin is, what it was like
growin up because, um, you know our readers, our listeners will learn that you have Retinitis
Pigmentosa, but it was late onset for you, so I'm sure you have a lot to tell about
how you lived your life as a sighted person without any issues and how you
transitioned into into blindness.
Thank you, Ed. Um, I'm happy to be here and happy to tell my story.
My name is is Devin Fernandez  and, uh, I'm 58 years old. I—
was, uh, born in the Bronx in, uh, Presbyterian Medical Center. Uh, I lived at
at 580 Castle Hill Avenue in the Bronx, uh, to the
age of fifteen I have, uh, an older sister and two
younger sisters and, uh, we all attended Catholic
school from, uh, 1st grade to 8th grade and that, uh, was Saint John
Vianney, also in the Bronx. And, um, it's amazing that
as a child — first, second, third grade — I was able to walk away
from my apartment building at least a half a mile away
with no concerns of anything happening in, uh.. Today, um parents
don't walk a block away without, you know, keeping an eye on their children, so times have
changed tremendously. And, uh, and during that time I was
in Catholic school. I was an altar boy so I was very uh heavy into
serving Mass and, uh I, I enjoyed that, you know, tremendously
and actually had aspired to join the priesthood
uh, at one point.
And then, uh, um, I guess life changes and decisions, uh
change as well. The, uh, as growing up as a kid, as I
said I had three sisters and, uh, being the only boy gave me some
privileges but uh not many. You know
I did get some special treatment at times but most of the time, the girls got the
treatm-- you know the better side a the deal. The friends I grew up with all
grew up doing the same thing--we used to go down to the park and play basketball,
play handball. You know, stick ball was one of our good games.
We used to bounce the ball off the barrel, dis?ing balls,
and, uh, you know games like that Ringolevio and Tag
and and ?Skellzy, which was a checker game, um, these were all games that
are really very rarely hear about now and um.
so we you know we grew up pretty, uh, pretty normal, as far as we were concerned, um, and then
as we got older, you know, the neighborhood changes and so do the attitudes and
sort of my attitude, and sort of my friends, and, uh, my parents saw me going
down I guess, a road that they didn't want me to go down, so, um, they
had made that decision, obviously, long before I was in trouble
to move to the Island and, you know, bring some fresh air and
get us out of the city life. So, uh, we ended up moving out when I was
15, uh which was a big change for me. I was just about to go into high school and
leaving my friends behind was uh--was hard to say the least. Not only
that being a new kid on the block, and starting school new,  it was, you know, a  pretty
trying experience. So, uh, which worked worked out very
well, um, you know I went through high school and when I was in
11th grade I met my, uh, my wife and,
You know it wasn't till ten years later--eight years later--that I asked her to marry me.
me. But, um, you know, we dated on and off, we went out with
other people. We, you know, experienced a normal teenage life
out on the Island, uh, going to the drive-ins and hanging out
and, uh, again times are different than they are now, uh,
We used to all congregate in this field that I'm at right now, at the library.
we would be fifty, sixty kids on a given Friday or Saturday, just hanging out here and not causing
trouble, but just had no place to go. So this is where we went and uh there's a big
field behind us and we all used to be out in the field and, uh, it was pretty
nice until, you know, the police would come and chase us out, and we'd go somewhere else, and they'd chase us outta there
and, you know, this happened every weekend, um, and it was a cycle
and, uh, but we never really caused any trouble, or or destroyed any, uh,
any property so um then after that you know we would finish
high school, went away to school, um, came back from
school, uh, met my uh, not met my wife, had to ask my wife to marry me prior to
leaving.
Um, we got married, uh, we started, um, our
family, probably nine years later. So we had established a
home before starting our family.
We were, uh, we were doing pretty well, and just prior to my
son being born I was an electrician and I uh
short-circuited, or slipped, into a electric panel which, uh,
knocked out a 3-story building, and what ended up happening is my
screwdriver hit the ground and the hot bus on the panel and it just welded to
the panel. But there was a, an arc that, uh, you know,
welded that panel, that screwdriver to the panel, and the flame from the
arc, had, you know, come.. bounced off the panel, about three feet
then, which burned my my hands and my face. Uh, it was in
September, and my sleeves were rolled up to my elbows so everything that was
exposed was totally burnt.
I remember being pushed away from the panel
by something or someone, and I hit the ground, I opened my
eyes and I couldn't see, and I was like, oh no I can't see and I started
to shake and I was, you know, um, obviously upset about what was
going on but yet I could still hear the panel exploding in the background, uh, so
I crawled my way out of the room by memory and when I got out of the
room I noticed that the basement door to the, to um,
the door to the basement which we were working in was open, and I could see the light. I was like,
Thank God, I could see, and then I looked down at my hands and I was, totally fried.
The skin was peeling off, it was black, uh, it was, uh, a
shock and that's, that's exactly what happened, I went right into shock. Um, my hands started shaking,
I was, you know, visibly upset, actually, emotionally upset.
I, uh, followed the light outside and when I got outside there was a
parking maid, or a parking lot, I forgot what they call them.
A parking lot attendant? A parking lot attendant — not an attendant, who
hands out the tickets, uh, you know, um, enforcer, an officer... A meter maid
A meter maid. There you go.
So, uh, I climbed out like five or six steps, and as soon as she saw me she
sat me on the floor and, uh, at that point, she was, you know, she was trying to comfort me and,
I would, uh... She was questioning me, and in my opinion I was giving all the right
answers but they kept questioning and kept asking me the same questions
so I was like either stop asking me the questions or, you know, uh cause
I'm getting tired of giving you the same answer. I would look at my hands and
again I was in shock, boom, my hands, my nerves, my my whole nervous system was shot.
Uh, my face felt like it was just an intense sunburn,
uh, and I hadn't seen my face at this point. So I'm looking at my
hands and then all of a sudden I just calm right down, and, as if nothing happened and I
talk to the to the meter maid and we uh, you know, she was telling me don't worry,
ambulances coming it's coming and I was like OK whatever and then or somebody right back into shock again
and so this happened from what I understand the endless only took about
fifteen minutes which which is pretty good. And during
this time I was coming in and out I was you know looking around me I was gathering a crowd and
I looked up from the building that I was working in and you
know it was in the actual building I knocked a whole building out people were looking out the
window staring at me and you know I just could see my hands and I could see our bed my
hands were but I still didn't think it was bad
. Excuse me and.
Finally the ambulance come and they wrap me up and take me to the hospital and the
whole time in the hospital I'm still like you know OK you know I got to go home I got some to do
today this evening after work and without realizing it
you know the extent of my injuries. So they stripped me down and
again you know on to questions from the doctor with the same questions over and over and
over again and then I was really starting to feel the pain from the burns. And I
told the doctor I said this is it I see no more questions. I says give me some for the
pain and at that point told me that it was going to have to incubate me which was to
stick tubes down my throat and I was no way you know doing that I got a good idea
today and he's like you know I'm going home. He says I got to do this because if I don't
do it now. I may have to do it later when you throw twelve so he goes we don't want to
do that so he did that they put me out.
It turns out I was put into a drug induced coma
for three days.
The drug induced coma for three days and in a coma
. You know with my eyes and I would see the nurses working on me and I
could see them peeling the skin off my hands and dressing my hands and my hands are
suspended up in the air after they were dressing me address the hands
and my eyes were swelled shut so what I could see was really
very very little and then after about three days I was able to
see I was able to open my eyes wide enough to see that
you know I had sight which you know we're very happy and then I looked at my hands and I was like
oh my God what's this.
And then we went through the whole process of what happens as a burn patient and
the nurse was like oh you know you don't so good we're going to
have to take you for a bath and will you know do your shower will scrub
the wounds and we'll put you in another room because I was in critical care at that point
so I said OK that sounds great. And then what they did is they put me in the
shower but they when they scrape the wounds they draw a skin
so I was on fire so you know the host's nervous system
shutdown damaged right back into shaking like a leaf and you
know so they have said they began.
But they still put me in another room and they will come in every night and
do just that.
They give me an injection painkiller and then they would literally
scrub the skin off the burns
the flesh so that it wouldn't scar and when puss wouldn't get infected and I
was their main concern of infection because what they did for me and one area in
one room they were doing something different to somebody else in another part of the hospital and the
live part of the floor because we were all in a burn ward
and and not to regress but my
my wife at the time was eight months pregnant when I when I had this accident. So when she
came to the hospital they told her listen if you get upset at all we're going to have to ask you to
leave. So they prepared her to you know what I was going to look like
and I was like the mommy has to wrap my head was wrapped I mean tubes coming out
of my nose it was red blood spots and you know if
I could only actually I did see pictures of what it did look like so.
So after that we go into the other ward and what happens is
I just found a doctor I can't take this you know. This concepts like torture you know the
constant cleaning this is don't worry. You know tomorrow you're going to go into surgery and you won't have to worry
about the hands we're going to do skin grafts on your hands and fingers in your arms and you know it you
know that'll stop us. OK great so I was happy for the surgery and went
to surgery and they had told me prior to this that they were going to take the skin from my
legs to put on my hands so that they take like a half a layer of skin
and they attach it to the flesh. It grows back the other half a layer
and so both has grown and so I get the layer on my skin that was taken off
replaces itself and then the new layer that was put on my hands really grows on my on my arms in my
hands so I say OK great. So they did that and then I come out of surgery and this is
you know all is good I'm in good shape and the nurse says OK now we have to
clean the legs we mean the same thing will happen with the hands we got to do
with the leg so you don't get affection so I went to the same thing again with I think a
cold barring any They come in and they say
they give you the so that you know take the edge off and and then they start scrubbing
and it's almost like an abrasive.
OK I had that they using and was sailing and they scrub and scrub in to
get off the dead skin and in fact not the infection but the gross
I guess you know.
So sapien with that is I wasn't healing quick enough so they put
me in these hot baths which was salt that which again the my fire
you know and so eventually the
legs were fine and now I had to wear specially
made gloves and I know what is close to two years and
I was able to take the gloves off one hour at a twenty four.
So for two years I would these special gloves. They called job's gloves
and enormous Tanno skin colored and yes I
have probably three four five parities gloves so I can constantly wash and place them
and that's what helped keep the compression on the
growing skin from bubbling up and scarring in
and I growing properly so would be N..
What we call constant therapy they would clean
any sebaceous cyst that I would get they would cut in and drain him and
put him in and then we do it again and found we can finally that
stopped and I went for therapy for the hands and
so it was from I was in the hospital two weeks from my surgery
and after that two weeks later my son was born my first son was born
so I was you know to hold my son for two years you know
with my own hands because of the accident.
And so when I landed and was going to low
voltage so I was working on high voltage panels I went to
low voltage security systems which I had done prior to become an electrician
and I worked for numerous companies on and off
and as I you know worked through I started my own
business. I would do both you know just to keep it legal I had to have
my insurances and everything with my business and then I
was a service tech for you know several other organizations and.
I started to notice that when I walk into somebodies house
it would be dark and she wouldn't be dark in the room but my eyes thought it
was dark and it would take a while to to adjust as al-Qaeda is you know
no biggie I just get you know from my to doctor my eyes were having a little issue. Then I
walked down from upstairs down to a basement and had been blacked out
and take a wallop. Boom came back and then I started noticing
the brightness and outside was bothering my light my eyes so
I decided to go to the doctor and the doctor tells me he says
you know you have right now is pigmentosa. Saying OK so
that's how he said it as if you know I had a cold or I had floaters in my eyes but he never
elaborated on what the condition was what the disease was what the future was and I was like
OK so he says I see you next year and we'll see where progress is and I was
like OK so I had scar tissue on my retina from that explosion
.
Oh you know I had trauma to the eye because of that.
Yeah and it was only one doctor who actually made the
diagnosis that that's how this started the shock to the to the eyes
and the shock to the nervous system triggered it probably a dormant
gene that that I had and this is how you know
this progressed and how do you know.
At this point I am forty years old
through forty and I just think that forty three years old with the first
diagnosis.
OK Then at forty four I think of going back because the symptoms started
to you know to get worse and
that's when he told me you know I tell you you have right now is pigmentosa so then
that's when I looked it up and I was like oh my goodness I haven't there's a chance that I can actually go
blind which I totally didn't believe because my eyesight was still in pretty decent shape at
that point I was still driving a car I was still driving at night and I
thought I had really pretty decent vision. And slowly
but surely the system symptoms started to present
themselves. First I started losing my depth perception
then I start to lose in my ability to adjust
between darkness and lightness and I had
gone to a doctor and didn't even know I was losing my color vision at the same time thinking
OK I can see that I can see then when I went to the doctors clearly
clearly clearly evident that I can see I can make out
most of the colors and so then I went to a specialist in
Manhattan New York and he you know he diagnosed so yes you
definitely have retinitis pigmentosa and this is a hereditary disease and
somewhere along your family line somebody in your family has had this and
it tracing back along our family line. We don't have anybody who had blindness and in our
family although some people some of our family had eye issues it was never
blindness you know that the net wasn't correct corrected with
corrective lenses. So the
system and symptoms started to progress
. I started to limit my
driving time where I was you know how I don't know how I was getting back and
forth to different areas of you know the island I would make sure
that towards the end of the day before it got dark I was making my way home.
And even sometimes in the daylight if I would
go from a bright street and turn into a shaded area I'd have to
stop and wait to the my eyes adjusted and then
continue on you know a neighborhood road which was pretty dangerous
. And it scared the hell out of me because I was not
concerned most you know the hurt myself but I was really concerned her and somebody else
and you know having him say you know you know you had eye problems are you still behind
a wheel that's a problem. You know two issue. So
again this is another step in that in the change. I went
from seeing the road signs a big highway signs to not even
seen a road within six months and
the progression started to rapidly take its course.
I got to see other doctors I go to three different specialists and they put me
on one of the doctors had described it as it's an
auto immune condition where my retina is attacking. I mean
my immune system is attacking the retina so auto
immune right not to be. So it slowly took bites out of my
rent and start with the left eye and then you know
manifested itself in the right eye and continued to destroy the retina
to the point where I had to stop driving all altogether.
However I will say that it was my decision and it was
a hard decision. Because I remember even making decision not driving at
night was a hard decision. You know because now it's time to put the burden of
the transportation on to my wife and at the time I don't think she
realized to do agree of loss that I had
because I certainly didn't and I you know I forced myself to do it as long as I could
where I would come home some days and my stomach would be in knots you know just
just for the trip home.
So in your original record for locations.
Yes. Yeah. So bouncing around you know I would I could do one hundred miles in a
day from one end of the island to the other
and you know as you can imagine it just you know it's so
frightening that that had that had to stop so
I stopped driving at night. And at that same time
I had to give up my my job because it was part of my job I had to
deny service emergency service and so that then that's when
I forced myself to to go full time in my own. Business
which will worked out great because I was able to dictate my own hours
and then the issues started to come up when the weather changed. You
know I would look forward to a rainy day because I was able to see better in a rainy day
or dark cloudy day I was able to see better and then it got to the point where that was
you know bother me now I was getting too dark so I couldn't do that then
and as the condition progressed I was
lose work. I was you know I couldn't you know if
you know a goat go to somebodies house and work in their house and
not be worried about damaging something or. You know knocking something over
that you know was was pretty expensive and you know people see it like
I work in an ad as they are too thrilled with that.
You know Sir George my security. Yeah this guy's right.
So you know so that that that became an issue
.
So I land of having to stop my installations. Well when I had an insulation I
would sub it out or I would do it with somebody else
and I make them do the work and I just supervise and tell them what to do which is what I do now but
you know like a field he was
absolutely absolutely So right now that's how I maintain my business
because for the most part every installation that I've done I recall
very vividly in my mind.
I'm what's what and what's where and so forth so when when I do
go to somebodies home or business I I actually tell them OK notices
over here and as you know it sometimes amaze that really I can't believe you remember that or
you know because I did the job so I know where it was. So
then the same thing when it comes to programming panels and cameras and so forth
I dictate to the person who's helping me with what has to be done
and and it's right there in front of them. You know so it's the works are very
very good
. So I had a major impact on the practical side of life. You
have an effective motion.
Emotionally I it's a
good question because I I can't
answer that because as it went from stage to stage I just dealt with each
stage as it as it presented itself not really thinking about the
outcome.
You know so you just going from stage to stage was difficult
at times but. Smoove as
well you know so and I
had already started training in martial arts prior to get my diagnosis
so I I decided to train as if I had lost my sight
so I would train my eyes closed and I just in a dojo I would do
that in the street so I do that looking for something in my garage you know I close
my eyes or I do it in the shower. You know looking for the soap and
shampoo in a towel and doing things and then when I came up of course something that
it did that startled me I opened my eyes and and that's how I train myself
with the cane and I was going now into Manhattan and
as bump into people in a lot of times it's not a good thing to
bump into people because they don't know what your intention is and then you know you can get an
attitude from from people thinking that you do and it being aggressive time so
what I would have done is that I got the cane so that people would know I have a visual impairment
so this way you know he would usually ducking.
Yeah strictly as communication and a learning device for me
for you you know it's no formal training or no formal training it
. That's right that's correct
. So let us you know say you know you have a world people
which is commendable.
And there's no borders or systems of the key
here.
Yeah and I did that I think I can assess it for safety you know
because like I said you could walk down the street in New York City bump at somebody and you have an issue now
you know which for the most part I never had you know I guess that's just
my own interpretation of of people in New York
City you know in the major city anyway. But so
I started doing that and I you know I was walking down the street with
my eyes closed which is scary and then I'm thinking wait a second I don't need to
walk downstream eyes close I have sight you know so why am I doing this but at the
same time I wanted to learn how to do this without the say so in
the short run
. Oh yeah you know it was strange because I was like you use
what you got on you know.
But at the same time I wanted to learn you know what happen if which I
still never thought it would happen. And as my
vision did decrease and the symptoms were obvious
I hooked up with the commission for the blind and this is all done through my family actually my mom
researched it and no information from Dr
No information off of it from the doctor that this you know and
he was just the eye doctor that day. That's on the corner you know that I went to see
just because and it wasn't a specialist at this point and then when he saw
you guys are going to specialise and they were like oh yeah I need to do these different tests and it would
only prove how much I had lost you know which I didn't even know I had lost
from from the tests that they did and sometimes I don't want to go to a doctor because I knew that he's
going to tell me I was more you know my plan you want to hear that
. So I went to the commission and they
actually gave me quite a.
What he called of quite a few
different avenues to go down. They first they went we went down and the
technology because I had my business I still had to you know write a bills and
estimates and so forth so they they help me with the technology part of it I
went of commuting back and forth from Manhattan to Long Island to three days a week
for these classes and an hour ago which of introns
playhouse I went to Baroque. Yeah I went to college
which I did several classes of several workshops or programs with them
. I went to the commission. A
Catholic until Catholic charities as a Catholic Charities in
Manhattan as well.
The Jewish guilt I think that a Jewish guilt Catholic
Charities in Manhattan put it Catholic charities on the island would come to my
house so that there was foreign sources.
Yes you know working for a lot of people. Yeah.
And those services you know for the most part
I.E. since I was cited I you know I had a real good
idea how to clean my house you know put things away how to cook and so forth but you know some
of the things that they did for me was it was so obvious they were an obvious you know the you
know just the safety aspects of cooking and you know that I just never paid
attention to because I just took for granted that you know I could see enough to you
know avoid them and they sort of mocking in labeling things
told in the washing machine and you know I made it my my
keyboard so that you could easily find the you know certain letters.
Which was a tremendous help and then I was using the
dark black markers right.
So a normal pencil normal pens because they consider any moron can see pictures in a
newspaper anymore I can see the T.V. I couldn't make out
what was actually going on I could see figures moving but you know I couldn't really
follow to the shows and then
you know again that the commission you know help me to adapt to that technology
to technology that I'm using now which is a joyous program and
Jaws is totally audible whereas I command
the keep it in and you know it'll read whatever I'm
asking it to read. We started to zoom tech to check
my progression was so quick that tech program just an
uber very quickly and it was get me dizzy you know I have to I just so
much to see the word Mousehole Screecher the whole movie screen moves with you and
say OK this isn't going to work. So I picked up on the joys
and that's what I use now and I so I still have issues
sometimes with the joys and I think for the most part it's not the issue of the
program but the way that the programs are formatted
all the websites are formatted. Some of them are just not George friendly road
users as you know no matter how you what you do
it's just lessen the frustration or patience for however you want
to put it and I'll go through that a little bit and then OK that's enough and
I shut it down and so at
that point I you know I had lost the privilege to drive.
I like my job I was losing money and my business
I had no income coming in. There was really no you
know means of income because you know
what I had depended on in the past was no longer available to me and
I thought I still have a wife and two boys in school home and two dogs and.
So you know I started meditating a lot and going in
wooden and this is all you know I hope the martial arts training will
help in this.
But pride to martial arts likes to meditate as well because I was taught I was
more spiritual and religious kind of person so the
meditation come came comes easy and it's comforting and
so I would do it and I would also ask you know what's the
purpose of what's going on here. You know you know
why am I going through this and I don't want to be why me why me why me.
Because I look at so many other people who have other issues and situations and
you know they move forward and and that's what I wanted to do I don't want to be a limey kind of
person I wanted to be how can I so
wish
. Yeah yeah it was it was
reaching deep into into myself to you know to know that you know
there's a purpose for my life and the course that you know my life
take is taking for me I felt that there was a reason for that.
You know so I would always ask in my meditations. Well you
know what's what's the reason. Who can I help who can I serve
you know just give me an answer of you know what to do and
so during that I was kind of like well what are the things I can do one of the things I can I
can share is the martial arts because I've
been doing it a while knowing more thought
about two years three years prior at
that point I was just going into my green belt was you weren't you were not a whacko
before you do it.
No no no no and when I finally got my
black belt my vision had
decreased quite quite a bit where I was still
driving but I was limiting your writing you know.
And I was still able to see a poncho still it'll see a kick you know as you know
it is all good and then out of
a different a different world it almost seems like you know step from one
world into another and that you know so. During my meditations I
was you know I wanted to continue to work out and I wanted to
find a place that other blind people work so I can you know relate to them and we
started doing some research and they were finding places and the nearest place was
in Manhattan and Saito which is a crowded studio there
was a place that's on Twenty third Street between six and
seven and they offer a program for the Blind which is you know fantastic program
and I I started going there and I was
I was like this is you know it's too far to travel just to come and work
out. So I started to talk to my mind start
there and I mentioned to him you know I want to start a program actually spoke of my so my sister
who's co-founded a program and so is Tom you know I have
to do something you know. But I just don't know why she is or why don't
we develop a program and you know that's a great idea.
We we started to do first things first we had to get a place to hold
it so I spoken to my instructor and I told him that you know I wanted to do this
and he goes that's fantastic because why don't you do it here. I says well that's great but I want to
be able to do it for free. So he was like OK well then
do you still do it here you know so he and he has been our biggest supporter
you know from day one and we're going on five years now. We started in two thousand and ten
and you know May fifteenth May two thousand and fifteen will be five years
and so here again he's been a tremendous supporter and we went to
see you know who can we get to come to these organising classes and we
went to different organizations and outreach to you know
how do you form your organization officially at this point was still an idea. OK
So you know we wanted to know if there was going to be a market now that you know marketing the
interest rate you know and it is a
great interest however. Things
that affect the blind such as transportation are an issue and
timing and what have you.
So once we establish that yes we can do this and we hope that when
I die in Freeport road was one of the first people we
spoke with investors to support their work record and so
we spoke with them and then I when I spoke with a group Helen Keller
out in Huntington at the time
I went and reached out to other groups of reach out to the veterans and
we will start to roll and the next thing we limit having to do
was to stop talking about it and set a date which we did and we promoted it and
we had a tremendous turnout. Initially and.
You know and we had expected to get a decent turnout and we also had expected some
people say this is great to says that's so good you know I like the program but it's
not for me. But with that with that we're learning
that part of it that's what can this mean
to him to doing other things other than a martial arts program initially was
going to be martial arts yoga and meditation which is what we do on a on a
weekly basis now in which the program or other it's just the name of the program
is third eye insight and that also came to my meditation
because that's how I used to meditate through the third eye which is located at the center of the
forehead and I always open my third eye and step into and you know
it's my place of rest and peace and tranquility.
So we started the program and then you
know we realize that not everybody is into martial arts not everybody's into the punching and
kicking which is totally understandable.
So we started to incorporate some of the outside events or recreational events
swimming in swimming swimming was in the in in our thoughts what hadn't been
you know political that we hadn't set up a
class or for that or a program for that and so we
go horseback riding we went kayaking for the first year then went
skiing then we we went
fishing pole all the different things that would do bull
and all these huge algae archery and we did
an archery program we did you know throwing knives and you know stuff
that I felt that interest me and would interest others you know
pretty outdoorsy guy I like to be active I like to do different things and and I
want to bring out you know about and around so others can experience the
same pleasures and then as the network started to grow
you know we met with you Ed And you do that
water skiing and you know snow tubing you just
you know you just went on I was also on your program. The
program which was at the time and my money
was very helpful and you know we find out
we'll with a lot because all students get together you know we will have similar
conditions but some of the factors are going on in our lives all
because of a tremendous you know and we will you know
and we're lucky because in our group were able to talk freely and not be
offensive and joke around and people would be like oh yeah I did that too you know
I can't believe you know that you know so something that you may not share with somebody to say because they
may not understand it.
You know somebody in the black community finds a humorous you know oh that was funny because I did the
same thing you know you know it was going to your program to use against
people who are sitting home.
Feelings are themselves human life is over all it was person by
is an opportunity not to come out and share experiences and share
opportunities to do that. Yeah meet new friends I mean you know there's a whole
community has developed of you know through your your brother and friend
. Yeah they're so into really now.
Yeah yeah and you know and the thing is you never know who you touch
or how that person's touched you know so
those are some of the definite positives you know which is which I like to
bring out and everything you know and
even just the way you speak about yourself it needs to be in a positive you know I
can't do that you know that's not positive you know positive How can I do that
you know let me know I get can I try I don't you know I want to do that you know
and it is events that I want to do that the
community won't let us
. Yeah you know you guys are crazy can do that. So now we can I can I can
relate can but they won't so we had educate them you know a
little bit more for me
. So you know the group has grown we've you know
life is changed.
My children have grown and you know so
this is been probably.
I'm guessing so far so probably almost
. Jeez thirteen years now I think
since I known about it too
. I am today and and where I am today is that I'm almost totally
blind right you know we live in such an earth I have light perception
I can see sometimes contrast black and white everything is black and white
so it could be red and white it can read like a science I can see red sometimes
and yellow as well I think I do but like white on
black black on white. You know which works out good because he's a black so I can see
the silhouettes of people.
But I'd lend it having to go for a seeing eye dog and I got my
first dog about a year and a half ago and again is at it as a
necessity to stay active and you know I was seeing
changes in one of the things I noticed Journ my progression
through this condition is that I would go to the same and I go
for music lessons because that's what I was doing. I would go into the city for music lessons take a
semester have a week off two weeks or three weeks off come back and
things I was able to see two three weeks ago were different. So so that's an
obvious change. You know where I didn't notice that change because it was so
gradual and you always were like you want to do
you know that was something I wanted to do I was on my To Do List
bucket list yeah I always wanted to be a black belt and I
always wanted to play saxophone. So
I decided you know the opportunity came up at the lighthouse. I found out about that program actually there was
a program in visions in Manhattan on Twenty third Street
as well. But they didn't they offer drumming drumming and guitar right which
I wasn't interested in either.
But I was interested in learning a Saxon when I found out about the lighthouse as I well you know and we let
me check it out in for the first time I walked into you
know first class I was loving it and the teacher that I had was fantastic because
he was teaching a blind student and you know
and he knew that and that's how he taught that's how he prepared his classes so I would
record every lesson and go home practice so I rented a
sax for the first couple years and until I purchased my own
and then I go home and practice every time with the sacks and it was it was
you know it's really good and he's kept me interested in it till today you know which is
you know it is it is amazing for me because a lot of times
you know I'll pick it up and I'll do it for was OK that's enough and you know put it down or go through spurts
or on whims or whatever you want to call them but if I would take
the summer off because there's no summer class and go back the next semester in
September is a big change and that's when I really started to notice oh
man this thing is changing pretty quickly you know. So
again another adjustment and that's when I realized I needed to dog and stop doing any of those
things so I got a dog went for the training at Smithtown Guide Dog
Foundation in town New York and you know
from there it's it's been it was too
. I felt uncomfortable with the dog where I was more consulate my
cane and because I was so used to stick and I was so used to my routine and
everything I could still do without a dog but a yard dog made it so much easier and
now it's the opposite now. I want a dog right. You know just
just it's incredible feeling when she navigates me
through a crowd of people you know and he would tell where to go
and it's been a couple times in Penn Station where I'll get off the
train come up an exit where I'm not even familiar with that because you know I can't see
it anymore and I say OK go find it let's go and Bush takes his right where you got to go
and it really is a socal.
And so sometimes I walk that walk contestation a smile on my face you know
because she's just navigating me in and out in and you know she takes in Iran
it's being you know so. How do you find your tree leaving
no consolation because I remember you know the routine the school
I still do that I still do that and the reason I do that is because
it makes my life easier and you know I just go up there and it will go to assist.
So I'll take it but I'm not afraid to help. In fact you know I
think that that's a big thing you know when you need help to get it right you know
if somebody offers you help and sometimes I needn't take it anyway but you know because
personally I have a way they asked me if they want to help me you know as I said OK sure no problem you know
we were killed people all over hell the worst thing you can do you know
you're broken.
If you know it's our job to educate us or radio where
you know the you know some people read before this before they actually
you know you know how long they don't know where you can write without them or anybody else
.
That's exactly right and you know the biggest pot I find is that people don't pay attention
so you know I bump into people and it's not because of me but it's not because of the
dogs because they're not paying attention and you know others are texting and texting
and you know they got their head up in the air and I think I mean things are going to do but
but you know when somebody offers me help I usually will say showing that you know
unless there's an you know a reason why it's just and there's been days we ask no I don't need your help
and you know where do I look like I need to help you know but
you know for the most part if if especially in New York City if you stand on a corner long and two
traffic lights somebody says can you do you need help you know and they say one out of
six hundred people will offer you help but your course and want to six hundred people on a
couple blocks.
Yeah I don't like the numbers of homes but there are
people people people are very helpful here.
Yeah yeah I've always I've never had a problem either you know.
I've never had anybody give me wrong directions because for the most part I know where I'm going and I just need to
get oriented to where I am because that happened has happened
.
Yes So the progression has been long and slow and
and it is what it is and I you know I go for
checkups and my doctors and is in Columbia
Columbia University Columbia Presbyterian Medical Center and
he is does a stem cell research and gene therapy and
you know it's like five six years ago he says don't worry ten years from now we're going to have something do you
know. So I truly believe that before
my end of my life I'll have my vision back. OK So
one way or the other you know whether that's through God's intervention
or it's through medical intervention which to me is the same thing you know it's got to come
from somewhere. So I truly believe in you know
the way technology is going it's it's inevitable you
know whether it's full vision partial vision.
An adaptive vision you know with the glasses and the chip in the in the retina.
You know any of those modalities any of those you know
devices you know but we're not like
a year or so ago I was you know seen changes of course
but from where I am now I would take a year and a half ago Division I had a year and a half
ago and love it and you know I said OK you know it's much better than I had you know I got now
but you know and it's kind of amazing the things
you take for granted and you see you don't see or you pay attention to you
don't pay attention to you know and then when you kind of lose that
you can appreciate what you had but now it's already too late you know.
I'm appreciating what you have now is really you know you could do
you know so that's kind of the my day after day one day at a time you know
this is this is this is this today it is going to be a good day today and you know and usually it is you know those
obstacles happen you know things come across a table that you know you don't want to but they
and they come and they go you know so yeah that's
that's that's how I take it you know you know.
Unfortunately nobody can for about four years now and so yes you know a
dramatic decrease in your vision in the past couple years but I've
never known you have never heard the story before about your ass and a
bunch of claims are. Down. That was pretty
rough.
Yeah you know and you were one of those is a tough thing I
mean how much I want to be a huge accident give you the
strength to get through but you know you know you know it
was it is it's.
It's hard to say because when I first when the explosion first happened
and I was blind I was like I was in shock I was you know and I shock physical shock but
fear fear you know fear is more of like you know God I can see oh my God I can
see and that was traumatic you know that was really
really pretty I wakening eye opening
it you know but then when I saw him say oh good I can see.
So but even from that same day from that day or from
when I was able to open my eyes again I always felt that there was something wrong
with my eyes you know and I didn't want to
verbal to say it you know because I don't want to you know bring him out as they say manifest
something that's not there. You know but you know it just happened it just was
there it was it was obvious it was you know something that was becoming unavoidable.
You know I just couldn't ignore it you know and so on.
But that's you know that's that's that's the story and that's that
that's the path you know went today.
We Like I said we have a beautiful program we have a lot of people joining our
program and your family your universe supported the program
. Yeah
yeah absolutely.
Absolutely and you know one of the other things was is that I wanted to be an
example for my boys you know because you can't give up if you give up. What are
they going to say when life gets tough you know. So it's
it's that kind of a catch twenty two and you know you you want to be feisty you want to give
I mean I want to say you know I'm not dealing with this you know. But you got to do
it and the way you deal with it is you know is it kind of like an example to
everybody else you know you know that responsibility punky you know strength
is you know if you wanted on absolutely you
absolutely certainly was because you know again like I said I needed to be an
example. I was pushed into that you know what as a
father an example anyway.
You know so people don't vote that it was not
an issue but you know you want to say I want to do the right thing I wanted to you know.
Because you know we all know that there are going to be difficult times in
life. So you know how you deal with them you know
and how you look at them and you know it is really your choice you know you
choose to look at it in a certain way I choose to look at it
in you know the way I look at it I choose to look at it in a positive way regardless of what it is
even you know people say like if you look at a positive way there's always something that comes out of that
you know and and this is a positive you know why I will lose my vision and now I have a
program for blind people you know if you've got scores of well you know
I like to think that and I almost think that that's not true
because they were looking to be out there looking for something it's not that you know
you know or something miraculous that they can do for themselves you know they were looking for things to
do there and and even now once I join this community I've seen.
Opportunities open up for the blind and I don't think we're there before you know
because now more blind people are becoming aware that they don't have to sit home. You know I'm not
just a number that you know it's on the
disability list you know. So you
know we have people now involved in every day of their
lives you know the transportation you know the people who
are looking to sign up voters and you know to get our voice
heard and so what do you want your students really
who say oh yeah go from here in New York City
Marathon
. I met her for the first time your program is not very
physical and to me.
Yeah yeah yeah she wouldn't go out without a dad and you know and she started taking the bus
by herself and you know she went for independent living and you know there's an example of
somebody who was booked for something wanted and growing and you know and that's
what.
Well I think it's really OK I understand what you're trying to save
your catalyst. Well I appreciate that you thought a lot of people
get from point A to point they continue on it which is
yeah I don't.
So when you meditate now you know a new
piece I mean seeing the program being more people of a community
to be interactive with you know does that help you feel
better.
It actually does.
I'm a big believer in visualizing what you
want you know for instance I am looking
to have my own facility and I really know what it looks like I've been
there I've walked through the doors you know I have it laid out in my head I know to
call and say no you know how everything I so I know what I feel that I know is there
inferentially it will be you know.
Yes So when I meditate I do visualize on that and I
also just fish and I was just trying to be calm you know
because as you know stress in life you know even as
positive as you want to be there is always something that comes up that you know kind of tweaks you and you could be the
easy stuff that you did when you decided you know I miss my boss you know running away
now I'm going to miss my bus or you know whatever the situation is
. Yeah you know how many times I have you know
I I still hold a lawn and last season I was
mono law and I shut it off I emptied the bag and I can find a lot more.
I say son of a gun.
I know I had a little color my life with a launch is what happened as I walked
away from it but I
lost. You know the funny things
and some of them you know we can share and laugh at it and you know and we choose
life that you know or if we bump into something I always laugh and say OK somebody out there is laughing
you know like OK watch this washes he's going to he's going to papa said you know there it is it's
OK It was fun hearing you know I mean one of them
two years ago.
Less two years ago this summer when you got you got it all you know to summer with her and
yet reclamation period together you're depending on it is going well I guess the fall comes and you
go back to the White House for saxophone lessons right.
She doesn't like it. Yeah that's exactly right exactly right
. So we we had to do some training for her here you
know to get used to it and you know the people I think I don't they sure are great about it
you know let's try this. We procure uneasy and poking a little easier and
because you know you got to get the dog in and escape you know so I did and she did you
know says I saw she was gone you know and then it allows us to realize OK
So Betty still play nobody got hurt and she would come and sit next to me you know and then she got to
the point where it wasn't all that hard all you know and now I go into the city I'd walk into the room she knows
where to go to go she rolls up and she says that she weighs you know until it's all really
so you know she got used to it.
Yeah. Yeah right I was can take that either way right. So that's the
counselor the trainer said Nicholson I said well maybe Sean like my
music you know is going to practice more or
less programs that were already programmed in doing there as well.
That's right that's right.
Which is a great program and is another point you know we partnered with the Y.M.C.A.
and they have reached and you know we were able to put together this program on a weekly
basis and you know they do for us and and we have
people who need that you know all elderly or you know
physically out of shape and they need it.
Easy exercise you know it was great it was time you provide
classes you provide that program and you know that's awfully early right.
Yeah yeah yeah. Everything so far is free you know we we work on a
shoestring budget and because my instructor allows us to use his
his facility has a huge expense that we don't have to incur. Right.
And you know so that right off the bat is tremendous
and we love organizations that help serve the disabled community
. You know all these events that we do are are centered around the disabled
so when we go surfing these guys are training us to say if
you know how to work around a disabled you know even when you go to
skiing you know they were rigged for disable the program.
Yeah you know when we go skiing you know you get three guys come follow you down the hill
you know and they make it seem and feel like it's so comfortable that you're not afraid to
take some of the fear out of it and you know there's always the apprehension but remove the fear
and and that's the big thing and when people start doing that and they start realizing I am I
can't believe I did that you know I can feel that you know it's such an
uplifting exhilarating feeling that you know they can't wait to do something that you know the next
thing you know. But also the other half is getting the word out and
telling people and getting more people involved you know because this still. I don't even
believe we have one percent of the population
. Oh OK So you know some people get a refund of about thirty
. Well we've we've got a few things you know we have a website
. I also have a public access station that
we we we have a show that will probably broadcast every
Tuesday and it's self defense
but it also deals with topics that involve the visually impaired
radio knows on Cablevision channel twenty. Oh and if you have
optimal park we'll have it soon as well.
You can you can see in our planet Mike my first
episode was with my instructor. OK second episode was with me in
another one of my instructors. Third episode we shot actually here at the library
third or fourth episode we shot here which is a nutritional episode
and the power of visualization.
Wow So so all this is on the west side as well yeah and that
is the you know you know you dub third eye insight
or Yeah and they're going to teach irony that's the way you write. Yes inside
. OK.
A.N.S.I. G.H.T. and people you know you through contacting you have
info at third eye and saying you can email me and reach out to me and
we also have a page there that forces for good and so so many other organizations that
are associated with or associated with the black community and so it's quite
quite informative and I mean you know
the Cablevision enough awesome
. Yeah yeah well you know
appreciating the time and he was vital information in the next three years.
You've come a long way. Yeah yeah. You've run the gauntlet.
Yeah you know like I said it's almost seems like it's different worlds you know
side it will to the blind world it almost seems like two different people you know from where I
was to where I am a well you know the whole change and what
we call a metamorphosis
. More recently you know we are very happy with us as we count
.
It's like ass yeah I say you can sleep sleep at night. Well
thank you.